are we absolutely sure what direction
we're going it's been more than six
years since zane malik left one
direction but on monday liam payne sent
fans into a frenzy with a tick tock
about the infamous moment
liam poked fun at the meeting he and his
bandmates harry styles louis tomlinson
and niall horan had with management
after the now 28 year old decided he was
quitting the band
are we absolutely sure what direction
we're going the singer shared that tick
tock video writing pov the meeting after
zane quit forgot i had this in drafts
are we absolutely sure what direction
we're going as of tuesday the video has
5 million likes and counting and over
193
000 comments
and in the caption liam made it clear
that it was all in good fun using some
laughing face emojis and writing quote
forgot i made this a while ago hope you
see the funny side
of course zayn made his exit from 1d
back in 2015 shortly after he left the
band's on the road again tour at the
time he explained in a statement that he
felt like it was the quote right time to
leave the band quote i'd like to
apologize to the fans if i've let anyone
down but i have to do what feels right
in my heart i am leaving because i want
to be a normal 22 year old who is able
to relax and have some private time out
of the spotlight
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
the band continued as a quartet after
zayn's departure but following the
november 2015 release of their album
made in the am they announced a hiatus
for the following year the whole time it
was just really exciting since then zayn
liam nile harry and louis have all
pursued solo careers
[Music]
and while one direction may not be a
thing anymore the guys continue to
support one another earlier this year
liam went live on instagram and revealed
that louis had helped him a lot
throughout the coronavirus pandemic i
was actually just on the phone to louis
who i haven't spoken to in a minute
which is quite nice i've been struggling
with it a little bit honestly louis has
definitely been there for me over the
past couple of uh weeks which i've got
to say thank you and when louis released
his solo album in january 2020 nile
encouraged his own fans to help make it
a success tweeting quote let's get tomo
right up the charts this album is
quality and deserves to be up there
[Music]
you